[Music]
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you to today's webinar on the human
somatic mutation database or hsmd
harnessing insight from real world
oncology cases and kyogen knowledge to
annotate variants and assess prevalence
introducing a new somatic database our
best kept secret
this will be presented by dr biata
litzenberger
my name is marianne and i'll be the host
and moderator for today's session
during today's webinar all attendees
will be in listen only mode to avoid any
background noise during the presentation
as for our webinar platform you'll see
several windows open in your browser
there is a media player window that will
be showing our presentation
depending on the size of your screen i
would encourage you to play around with
the sizes of the windows if anything is
unclear or too small
you can minimize or maximize using the
icons in the top right of the windows or
you can click and drag on the edges
there's also a q a section called ask
question
if you have any questions for the
presenter or regarding our solutions in
general please let us know here
we'll take some time to address your
questions during a q a session at the
end of our presentation
if there are any questions we don't get
to today we will follow up with you by
email
you'll also see several other
possibilities to open other windows at
the bottom of your screen
if you click these icons the windows
will open and when you click again
they'll disappear
so now i would like to introduce our
speaker for today dr biata litzenberger
piata is a global product director of
oncology for clinical decision support
software and interpretation services at
kyogen
prior to joining the kyogen team dr
litzenberger led clinical decision
support in the interpretation of patient
cases for several next generation
sequencing protocols at the md anderson
cancer center
in this role dr litzenberger was
responsible for providing alteration
interpretation drug and clinical trial
options to clinicians
now i will hand the presentation over to
biata
thank you so much for the nice
introduction and thank you all for
attending today
pyjamas curated knowledge can be used
for many purposes however we have
particularly deep curation in the area
of cancer research
as you know cancer is a disease caused
by mutations
while the majority of cancer is caused
by spontaneous or somatic mutations
many cancer relevant or
cancer-associated variants can be
inherited
to understand the complexity of cancer
genetics and the oncogenic potential of
mutation a resource is needed that
covers both types of mutations and hsmd
fulfills that need
data sets such as tcga and icgc provide
opportunities to identify causative
variants underlying human cancers
however most of the somatic mutations do
not have a noticeable effect and our
so-called vos's
and the prevalence of vos's in a cancer
sample hamper the distinguishing of
cancer-causing driver mutations
many approaches and databases have been
developed to prioritize cancer driving
mutations
most of these tools can be classified
into three categories based on three
basic principles
frequency-based methods which consist of
identifying mutated
mutations that are
more frequently mutated than the
background mutation rate
while this method is an essential step
at identifying driver mutations
as a standalone measure it's not
sufficient
and can be confounded by the fact that
mutations can generally occur with a
high frequency in the general population
the second principle is based on
computational algorithms that have been
developed to predict whether a mutation
is deleterious or pathogenic based on
concepts including evolutionary con
conservation
structural constraints
and the
physiochemical attributes of amino acids
but cancer driver mutations
predicted by this mutation are
computational methods like consistencies
and are prone to false positives or
negatives
the third method is purely manual
research by subject matter experts
sifting through the literature to find
publications that describe statistically
powered experiments that decipher the
biological clinical or disease relevance
of a mutation
this is an unsustainable laborious
effort and it's not scalable
over the last years many tools such as
ongo kb my cancer genome or the
jackson's lab knowledge base have been
developed to deposit curated variants
with evidence-based information about
individual somatic mutations into a
database
however they have limited number of
variants some of them less than 10 000
mutations that have been annotated
towards its biological clinical or
disease relevance
now as a scientist keeping up keeping
the pace with new discoveries is a
serious bottleneck
i hope this picture literally speaks to
the problem that we face as scientists
and
is that its valuable information can go
really undetected due to inadequate data
mining and variant interpretation
mechanisms
while mutation and gene prevalence
remain one of the
measures to identify drug mutation it is
important to use different genomic
oncology data sets to calculate
frequency data depending on the goal of
your research study
hsmd is powered by kyogen's aggregated
knowledge
since more than 20 years kaijans subject
matter experts and ontology engineers
have been using sophisticated curation
tools
and ontologies to transform unstructured
genomic and cancer-related literature
into machine-readable units with
semantic consistencies
the aggregated structured genomic and
cancer-related knowledge comprises of
biological phenotypic therapeutic and
outcome data that can be used to
understand the genetics of a disease
review available therapeutic options
decide on experimental strategy
or use this data as a part of
accelerating a drug development program
the kaiju knowledge base model allows us
to answer unexpected questions because
the database can transfers indirect
relationships build new relationships
and can find unexpected connections
for simplicity the most relevant
interconnected aspects that can be
explored in hsnd are shown here
this data set is genomically described
by refseq and ensembl transcripts
and is currently available in genome
bill 37
the clinical oncology data set comprises
of over three hundred thousand
de-identified patient cases
and we capture age and gender of the
patient
the interconnection between the variant
tumor type and investigational and
approved
drugs allows the user to explore
therapeutic relations
the mutation
is
characterized by four measures the
actuality classification according to
the amp guidelines
and activation type
molecular function summary
population impact and biochemical impact
all relationships are backed up by
references for the user to transparently
review the underlying evidence
so what are the sources that establish
those relationships and how many
relationships can be assessed through
hsmd
as of today hsmt hsmd contains over
uh three million curated alteration
findings
and this number goes up during weekly
updates of the content
the data within hsmd is derived from a
combination of information from the
kaiju knowledge base observed tackle
cases as well as public databases used
to annotate variants
these resources are combined to bring a
wealth of usable trustworthy information
regarding the biological clinical and
disease relevance of an alteration to
view
again this information comes with
appropriate citations for transparency
currently the curated data characterizes
over a million unique variants
encompassing 1 400 different genes
and nearly 11 000 cancer types and
subtypes as well as heritage cancer
syndromes
now i would like to spend a minute on
describing
more details about the oncology dataset
patient set that is incorporated into
hsmd
for more than a decade kaijan's
professional interpretation team
consisting of phd level scientists as
well as a team of collaborating
oncologists
has been researching and interpreting
somatic variants reported in cancer
patients
this clinically observed ngs data is
derived from a number of clinical
testing labs
using a variety of different sequencing
panels
and the manual variant adaptation
includes the activation type
um
the
actionability according to the amp
guidelines
and the range of tumor types include
solid tumors lymphomas and hematological
cancers
the oncology dataset is constantly
growing
and will add about 17 70 000 new cancer
profiles annually into hsmd
including 60 000 new curated variants
within oncology a number of different
aggregators publicly or privately have
emerged and each of the data sets has
its own strengths and limitations
some data sets may be larger than others
but lack a biological or clanglantation
other datasets may be biased towards a
certain disease
so in some cases combining datasets
together can reveal novel insights
as an example how does hmd dataset
differentiate from tcga
first of all it's important to recognize
that the kaijun dataset has a larger
sample size
it is more diverse
and it reflects a patient population
that tend to be post-treatment
the tcga data set contains a huge number
of variants noticeably due to bosses and
polymorphisms
whereas in contrast hsnb dataset
contains more than 260 000 unique
variants enriched for presumed
clinically relevant mutations
so if you ask questions what a potential
acquired resistance mutation that may
occur
due to extensive treatment you will
likely not find the answer using tcga
where the dominant samples were derived
from treatment naive cancer patients
what i'm trying to illustrate is that
it's important to recognize the
characteristics of each data set to be
able to use each of these data sets
optimally to answer your scientific
questions
now this graphic represents the number
of cases tested for each of the genes
from
comparing hsmd's data set in blue
to cosmic sample coverage from their
targeted screen data which is red
hsmd contains a large number of cases
tested for each gene providing a mean
for a robust and confident assessment of
gene and variant prevalence from
clinical derived cancer cases
so how can you access hsnb
in its first version the
kaiju oncology dataset can be accessed
via a searchable interface
the interface allows for flexible
searches by a specific term such as the
variant gene drug disease or searches
across the data set
so let's dive into the application and
within the next 10 to 15 minutes i will
walk you through some of the many use
cases hsmd can answer
so this screenshot here represents an
interface of our gene explorer
which allows for exploring and
prioritizing a list of genes with
specific attributes that are listed
within each column
the colored bars visualize the overall
genetic characteristics of a gene
based on the curated mutations within
each gene shown in the third column
for example the function column in the
middle shows the proportion of mutations
in each gene with which contain known
functional impact classifications
hovering over the colored bars will show
the details of the distribution that
make up the genetic characteristics of a
gene
all data in hsnb is hyperlinked for you
to dive deeper into a gene-bearing drug
trial or disease and respective
references
now what can you do with this
information
if an oncogene or tumor suppressor
status is not established one can
predict a potential status based on the
general composition of the alteration
types activation status and tier
classification
one can filter and so this data set to
prioritize prioritize a list of genes
that are known
tumor suppressors or oncogenes
with known functional
impactful mutations that are clinically
relevant
one can derive a list of genes that
contain mutations that cause splicing
defects
or
proteins based on
known functional impact classifications
and one can ask questions around which
gene on my panel are actionable or
which oncogene are targeted with the
most or least drugs
the variant explorer allows you to
explore and protest the list of variants
with specific attributes
so each variant is described with its
impact function actionability
with how many diseases it's associated
with and how many associations from the
literature are available for each
variant
now the column allows you to identify if
we have seen this variant in our
real-world oncology data set called
clinically observed
or if this is derived from our kaiju
knowledge base through proactive
curation
one can interrogate the variants by
asking the questions such as
what are
the mismutations with a known biological
and clinical relevance
that have been clinically observed
or
which biological relevant mutations have
associated therapies or clinical trials
or which biologically relevant variants
are emerging biomarkers without
associated therapies
and which variants have been mostly
characterized in the literature and
among those variants that obvious which
ones are associated with a lot of
literature
now the alteration explorer also
provides the meaning to search on a
codon position to identify how many
variants we have observed at that
location
how were they classified
and if we have seen them in our clinical
data set or
in our cargo knowledge base by
proactively curating the literature
you can explore hsmd from a disease um
general disease perspective for example
you could ask questions which diseases
were clinically observed and have turtle
egf are frequently mutated
the data can also be folded towards
which cancer types have we observed in
our clinical data set
but are not associated with clinical
trials or drugs
or what are some of the diseases that
have been associated with the most or
least variants
now
i will take um an example of a gene btk
to walk you through the specific gene
and varying content in hsmd
first of all um the left side contains
headers that serve as navigation pane
and allows you to easily and quickly
navigate and jump from section to
section
through the gene or variant specific
content
the gene summary summary allows you to
quickly understand
if function or if
to understand its function and if
somatic or german limitations
have been associated with a hereditary
syndrome or solid or hematological
malignancies
various link outs exist to other
databases
such as ipa
to understand in which pathway the gene
is located
the subsequent sections provide an
overview of the alteration types
and functional impact distribution
within this gene
you can easily find out
what are the known activating mutations
by clicking on the number
which navigates you to the alteration
section which then displays those
specific nine mutations that are known
to be activating
alternatively you can ask the questions
what kind of alteration types
are frequently observed such as indulge
smbs in this genes
and among
a specific
alteration type in this example missense
mutations how many are known to be
activating or predicted activating
again the alterations section will
automatically display just
mistransmutation
and
filtering capability capabilities allow
you to select only activating or
predicted activating mutations
but
what are really the affected codons and
a gene of interest at which mutations
occur are there any hot spots
hsmd displays a lollipop graphic that
allows you to identify where in a gene
and how often we have observed clinical
cases with a specific mutation at a
codon
and hovering over the lollipop you can
determine the amino acid position for
this hot spot
now you may want to review in which
disease is btk predominantly mutated
in this example
cll
and cllsll is shown up as the top
disease frequently mutated
if you don't see your disease in the top
10 on the screen you can either use the
arrows to navigate through those
34 diseases within
with with um
in which kaiju has observed this gene to
be mutated in
um alternatively
you can use the search box or
sort the table
by the presented columns to answer
additional questions such as how many
cases in each disease were tested for
this gene
now
for a particular disease of interest
such as cll
is in general important to understand
the mutational landscape
and this disease
so you can hyperlink to that disease and
navigate to a disease page
which provides
detailed information about the disease
and several sections shown here on the
left
the gene prevalence in this particular
disease is described in the gene
distribution section allowing you to
understand the top mutated genes
alteration as well as alteration types
and the top
reported variants in this disease
now from this to this graphic you can
determine that btk is actually not one
of the top mutated genes in cll
so you may be wondering
how actionable is this gene
and what are really the most clinically
significant significant mutations within
this gene
hsmd provides for each
variant in actionability classification
based on the amp guidelines which
determines the therapeutic prognostic or
diagnostic importance of a variant
we can then plot the actionability
across
the different alteration types in the
gene
this provides an overall assessment how
actionable a gene is
if it's rather an emerging gene or if
the actuality is driven by a small
number or large number of variants in a
specific alteration type
now there are nine mutations that stand
out to be clinically relevant
if you click on this these nine
mutations occur all at the same codon
that we have previously identified as a
hotspot in this gene
now if those variants are clinic
relevant
are there any targeted
are they targeted by a drug or cause of
resistance to a drug
and the drug section provides a list of
drugs its target and a therapeutic
response related to a specific disease
the information you will find in the
case of btk
is
that there are three drugs that are
approved by an agency
um
ibrutinib and zana rootnip however
the specific hotspot at codon 481
causes resistance to btk inhibitors
identified in a variety of diseases
i mentioned that each relationship is
associated with a references with
references and if you use the
drop down
next to each drug you will find the
relevant papers and a summary statement
to support this relationship
so what is known about this particular
variant
and what is the biological impact and
how frequently is a specific variant
has a specific variant been observed
so for each mutation hsmd organized
detailed information about the variant
in to several sections
shown here on the left
the description is an
expertly written summary of the
molecular function backed up with
hyperlinks references for your review
in the case of this ptk mutation that
causes resistance you can find out that
the c41 residue
is actually
a binding site for the btk inhibitors
and if mutated decreases the binding and
affinity of btk inhibitors
hsmd also displays the detailed genomic
description where this mutation is
located it's nomenclature based on the
different rfseq and ensembl transcripts
now alternatively hsmd allows you to
confidently distinguish variants of
uncertain significance from those that
may have clinical relevance
our variant scientists
did a targeted curation for this variant
and specifically research the literature
and database sources and determine
unknown impact
now many cancer-associated variants have
been primarily studied in a heretary
cancer or inherited disease context
hsmd provides comprehensive literature
coverage about a variant including
literature related to hereditary cancers
or inherited diseases that could shed a
light into a potential role in cancer
in this example we have
clinically observed this btk mutation
however a rolling cancer has not been
established yet
but has rather been
associated with x-linked aggramar
global anemia
if you are not really familiar with this
specific heritage disorder you can go
and jump to the bibliography
search for this specific syndrome and
hypothesize a potential role of this
mutation in tumors tumorogenesis by
reviewing um papers especially
functional study papers that shed a
light into its molecular functional role
and
potentially subsequently a role in
tumorigenesis
now going back to the example of the
c481
hotspot again
um
we can also ask question what is the
most prevalent disease at which this
mutation has been observed
data can be reviewed in the observed
clinical case distribution section
and additional disease associations
can be derived by searching through the
bibliography to find additional
relationships
so
how does
hsnd characterize rare variants with
early clinical and or principal
actionability information
so this is a tier 2 variant which means
it's a potentially clinically relevant
mutation
it is a known activating mutation and
the description
typically describes
early results or case studies with a
potential response
the fact that it's rare supported by the
frequency calculation from our
data set
now within
the
drug section
case studies are captured that describe
the treatment outcome of a specific
cancer type covering this mutation
however for this mutation it is not
established that the mutation sensitizes
the tumor to the drug but
when you're looking at investigations
and investigational
drugs
this is exactly being tested in clinical
trials for lymphomas plasma cell
myelomas and solid tumors
now hsmd can link directly to external
databases such as hgmv clinvar db snip
on kb
um and also incorporates population
frequency data from nomad and the normal
frequency data can specifically
transparently be reviewed to determine
if a polymorphism is predominantly
present in a specific
subpopulation
likewise the
variant page displays a variety of
prediction tools
which may be used as supporting evidence
to evaluate the biological role of
imitation
hsmd contains a clinical trial portal
that allows you to search globally
clinical trials based on specific search
criteria
such as the
gene
the the face and the recruitment status
a specific
drug and then country city and arranged
around the city
now each trial is hyperlinked and
within each trial record
it describes the specific
trial details its location
the eligibility eligible
alterations um drug and disease
um
and then you can also further go into
into deeper evaluation if you want to
understand the specific
drug targets
and its development status of this type
of drug
you can go to you can link to the drug
page
which then
it can display a proof brand name
synonyms and any relevant uh drug
targets
so in summary nhsnd contains a
comprehensive oncology dataset that
gives you access to a rapidly growing
real-world oncology dataset and
structured curated evidence
the content is updated weekly to cope
with the increasing number of variants
literature
sources and changing clinical relevance
the first version of hsmd
is developed in an easily accessible
user interface
now i hope that with the use cases today
i could show that hsmd allows you to
spot key mutations with driving
properties or clinical relevance
that the comprehensive aggregation of
structural content can bring valuable
scientific information to your attention
that can be used to accelerate new
discoveries or drug development programs
and to interpret confidently clinical
relevant variants
kaijun has been curating and organizing
clinical data for decades and we would
be very happy to be your partner by
providing access to our high quality
trustworthy updated and comprehensive
content in a way that suits your
individual needs best
please visit our websites to request a
free a clinical a free trial access hsmd
is a free trial access for five days
please sign up
and then thank you for your attention
and time today
thank you biata for that informative
presentation
so we'll now use the rest of the time to
answer any questions that you may have
please use the q a panel to submit your
questions for our speaker
the first question that we have today is
have you calculated co-occurring genes
and variants and is that data available
in hsmd
so we have done internally our
calculations on core current genes
however we have not yet implemented the
results of this analysis within hsmd and
we're expecting to do this over the next
year
okay thank you
the next question that we have is how
often is this database updated
yeah i mentioned that i'm doing my
presentation already but it's good to
repeat
hsmd's variant curation content is
updated quickly
the clinical data set
externally incorporates databases such
as nomad hdmd et cetera updated
quarterly
and then with hsm within hsmd we do
expect to add about 5 000 new uh curated
variants
per month and about 70 000 paper cases
annually
okay
another question that we have is
will this data be available in gr38
that's a good question um the initial
version is built in genome 37 and we
plan to lift it over to gr38 next year
okay
another question on data is will this
data set be available as a download
so our plans are to expose our content
through the api next year um if people
need early access
we do have a solution through our
services for selected uh selected
customers so
um if there's an interest in
an api uh access or
a customized solution um please reach
out to our professional service team at
kyogen
great thank you
okay um to follow up on an earlier
question
you mentioned that hsnd is updated
weekly
how do you ensure that the content is up
to date
yeah that's a good question and so our
content creation team has nightly
sophisticated queries that run on pubmed
guidelines and labels
and this identifies a set of new
articles and other references which are
then further processed through a
screening process
and which may eventually end up in the
task list of curators to then
characterize the articles um and um
place any additional information into a
structured format
uh based on uh the appropriate curation
protocols
um
the variants that have been clinic
observed at least twice over the last
year will undergo a review process to
guard to gather the latest evidence and
to decide if the activation type
collective function summary and
actionability is up to date
okay great
okay the next question is do you use ml
and crowdsource data for variant
curation
um that's a that's an interesting
question so um the curation of data at
scale is certainly a very complex
process and kaijan uses various methods
whenever it's appropriate without
compromising the position
so
the process of clinical and phenotypic
data curation is
laborious
intellectually intensive activity and it
demands deep
subject matter expertise and significant
personal resources
however it is important to recognize
that using the most appropriate method
at each step in the curation process is
critical for operating at scale and
coping with the
you know growing body of literature and
databases
so for example the process of
identifying and quickly prioritizing
relevant publications for curation is
commonly carried out by you know
querying articles
with computer programs
some of the manual screening the content
for its applicability and in this case
machine learning is actually providing
some valuable approach to enhance and
accelerate this process
um
the
there are other methods like the natural
language processing and
certain machine learning approaches can
further facilitate the seeding of
relationships so from articles in order
to describe for example a phenotypic or
genotypic relationship
and this really helps to focus
our human curators or domain experts to
spend most of the time to focus on some
of the challenging tasks that
machine learning and
other algorithms have not yet tackled
with high position
and that's typically um
precisely and organizing information
relationships
for
[Music]
clinical studies
capturing um really the the complex
relationships of uh interactions between
variants um
and the uh complex clinical outcome data
including including graphics um
supplementary material i think this is
still not very well refined using
computational methods and for us
um the high touch human review process
is still
um the cornerstone and of of our
curation to ensure high accuracy and
high specificity um and precision and
also relevance for for that specific
mutational disease
okay got it
um so it looks like we'll still have
time for a few more questions so if you
do have any questions for biata please
go ahead and submit them
if we don't get to your questions today
we will follow up with you by email
the next question that we have is
when will hsmd available be available
and is there a way to try it out
so hsmd is available
already
it
was launched in november
and so
you can try it out by requesting a trial
access first
um but please feel free to reach out to
also um our
specialties uh sales that allows you to
get more information about hsmd
and have a conversation with them as
well but it is available already
for you to to try it out
okay thank you and if anyone is
interested in more information
on the screen you can see our website is
www.digitalinsights.kyogen.com
you can find more information on hsmd
there and you'll also be able to request
a trial
okay the next question that we have is
will you be able to overlay the content
with patient data such as age
for example to review mutations in
pediatric patients
and so yes we certainly do have these
this capabilities to do that
however it is not part of the first
first release and um we'll have to
decide if it's uh in the sub if it's
part of the subsequent release
okay i think we have time for one last
question
our final one is you showed variant exam
excuse me you showed examples of just
variants does hsnd include fusions or
cnvs
yeah currently the interface only
displays small mutations
however
that's part of the next release we do
plan to add fusions and copy numbers
okay great
so we are um at the end of our time
if you have any additional questions
feel free to go ahead and submit them if
we did not get to your questions we'll
follow up with you by email
now i would like to thank our speaker dr
biata litzenberger for joining us today
thank you also to the audience for your
attention
we hope that this was informative and
helpful
so this concludes today's session on the
human somatic mutation database or hsmd
and we look forward to hosting you in a
future kaiju digital insights webinar
thank you again and i hope you have a
great rest of your day
you